premier élément en france vous avez des
soignants non vaccinés qui travaillent
ne sont pas suspendues en france et dans
les autres mers vous avez des soignants
qui par des nécessités des besoins de
l'hôpital sont en train de travailler
alors qu'ils sont positifs ça a été vrai
pendant l'intervalle c'est vrai
aujourd'hui encore donc ça existe
l'association l'hôpital est telle
qu'aujourd'hui des moyens sont pris sur
le terrain pour faire travailler des
soignants qui sont pressés midi femmes
vaccinées est porteur du virus
non mais et enfin sur le nour le
ministre en répondre à ma question à
commission des lois la semaine dernière
a dit qu'il y avait quinze mille
soignant non vaccinés pas soignants
suspendu soignant non vaccinées en
france
marianne dans un article hier dit qu'il
ya 5000 pompiers professionnels et
volontaires qui sont suspendus 140 ses
droits si c'est dans l'article
ci fera mais l'écouté maria riesch
chiffres agrégés marandi soignants qui
sont pas non je parle de chiffres
agrégés chaque collègue est-ce qu'on
combien sont ils à être suspendu
interdit d'exercer à être en arrêt
maladie en disponibilité ou en courant
ou dans d'autres positions à mithra dit
combien sont-ils en tout le ministre
nous a dit je ne peux pas répondre à
votre question dont on a un sujet de non
a répondu à la sortie du conseil des
ministres
regardez les les conférences de presse à
la sortie du conseil des ministres 600
infirmières 75 soit dans la vie
d'ailleurs mis quinze médecins on le
sait qu'avant les pieds ou et south
bénévoles ou bénévoles volontaires 140
pompiers ensemble et moi j'en connais
déjà quasiment on entre chez vous c'est
peut-être sais je sais je pense pas je
pense pas
les professionnels sont plus nombreux
que 140 je suis désolé je prenons le
téléspectateur public sénat à témoin que
marianne dit 5000 vous dites 140 je
pense
des chiffres exacts c'est très simple
c'est 0 5% chez les pompiers
professionnels et 2 % chez les pompiers
volontaires effectivement il ya deux
cent mille francs pompier volontaire à
peu près dans notre pays donc 2 % ça
fait 4000 voilà après ça n'est pas je ne
pense pas qu'on mène un raisonnement
qu'a paris franck happi exactement on
est dans un pays où il ya une loi et où
les professions sont régis par des
principes fondateurs quand on veut
toucher un principe fondateur on peut le
faire quand la nécessité de l'urgence
l'imposent est-ce que la nécessité de
l'urgence impose de
réintégrer dans des fonctions soignante
quelques centaines d'infirmières parce
que c'est ça effectivement pour ce qui
est des mails à cagliari caisse de
dizaines vu l'état d urgence cet été
voilà ce que la question en train de
dire est ce que est ce que est ce que ce
nombre très restreint changera quelque
chose à la situation des services
absolument pas et ça se ferait au prix
de la remise d'un principe fondateur de
ce qu'est la fonction soignante donc
attention on ne touche pas à ses
principes fondateurs au gré de la
conjoncture
[Musique]